in November the defense startup andrel
Industries released its latest
autonomous weapon systems Road Runner
and Roadrunner
[Applause]
M the road runners join andel's Suite of
AI powered unmanned products that are
shaking up the defense
industry since it was launched in 2017
andrel has found success as a defense
department contractor selling autonomous
vehicles and the software that powers
them today the startups technology is
being used across multiple branches of
the US military and in both the Ukraine
Russia and Israel Gaza conflicts the
company was recently valued at $8.48
billion andrel was created to help build
a new type of military to meet the
demands of a changing Battlefield we are
in a position where over the last
decades we have built the wrong things
we need a different kind of US military
and a different approach to military
power andal I think is a healthy
Revolution for the defense
[Music]
industry so this is fury it's an
unmanned combat aircraft that is able to
work in collaboration with man Fighters
with other Mann aircraft to hugely push
out the range that we can engage targets
at without putting people at risk that's
kind of one of the coolest things about
autonomous systems not necessarily the
fact that they can think faster or do
better than a person but they can also
just throw away their lives andral's
founder Palmer lucky is among the more
polarizing figures in the tech industry
my name is Palmer lucky and I'm a
virtual reality Enthusiast and the
designer of the rift lucky first found
success when his virtual reality company
Oculus was acquired by Facebook for more
than $2 billion but in 2017 lucky was
ousted from Facebook after a tumultuous
tenure let me just show you very quickly
what our software looks like this is an
example of what we think it's a pretty
intuitive interface the foundation of
andrel is Lattis a software platform
that serves as a Command Center of sorts
allowing a single human operator to
control and coordinate multiple
autonomous robots be they a drone a sub
or a mobile Sentry what you're going to
see at the bottom is essentially all the
different assets that are a part of the
team uh and then you're going to see a
graphical display that looks very
similar to a lot of the software that we
might use in in everyday uh life where
there's there's a map in the background
you're going to see multiple vehicles on
that uh software and each of them you
kind of know what role they're playing
Engineers are designing our software
much like the people who design the
kinds of software that goes on our cell
phones or on an iPad it's meant to be
very very user friendly Hardware Focus
defense companies um that's not that
hasn't been approached the US military
likes to buy things the whole contract
mechanism is set up to buy things and
just now I think generationally
culturally they're starting to catch up
to the idea that a software package can
be just as powerful as the thing that it
comes in but Angel's Tech isn't the only
only thing that sets it apart the
startup is also pursuing a business
model that borrows a lot of inspiration
from the tech world the way that the
traditional defense really large defense
companies are set up uh when they take
risk the market actually frowns upon
that risk being taken we are designed
completely differently as a company we
are designed like a high-tech company
the set of investors that we have and
ultimately hopefully when we're a public
company um it is expected that we take
risk on andrel says it's taking bigger
risks because it's betting that the way
we fight Wars is changing rapidly what
we're dealing with right now is a
disruption created by technology created
by the threats that we're facing andel's
Chief strategy officer Christian Bros
Likens this alternative to the Moneyball
system described in Michael Lewis's book
of the same name you guys are talking
the same old nonsense we got to think
differently in Moneyball the Oakland A
attempt to put together a baseball club
on a budget by employing computer gener
ated analysis to draft its players
similar to baseball you have to come up
with a strategy that is lowcost that's
going to allow you to build an
affordable uh you know sort of scalable
approach that's going to be successful
for military terms it's not relying upon
traditional military systems you know
that come in very small quantities that
are rather large very expensive very
Exquisite hard to produce hard to
replace very manned it's going the
opposite direction and relying on larger
and larger quantities of smaller lower
cost more autonomous military systems uh
that you can produce very quickly you
can replace very quickly Andel I think
recognized that there was a gap in what
some of the big primes were doing and
sought to fill that Gap thinking
differently about defense is something
that's hard to do if you've been very
successful working in your particular
way of thinking about defense that's
part of why anderol is so interesting as
an alternative mechanism since the end
of the Cold War America's defense
industry has undergone considerable con
consolidation in the 1990s the US relied
on 51 primary contractors today that
number is just five locked Martin Boeing
RTX Corporation northr growman and
General Dynamics according to a 2022 DOD
report fewer contractors has stifled
Innovation and undermined price
competition we live in a world where 80%
of weapons procurement goes to just five
companies one of the biggest issues is
Cost Plus contracts meaning they're paid
for time materials Workforce and then a
fixed percentage of profit on top
because that profit is a plus a lot of
vendors are incentivized for the cost
portion to be as large as possible as
well they can often make more money when
something takes longer than it was
supposed to they can often make more
money when they sell a solution that's
more expensive rather than a solution
that's less expensive and this wouldn't
be a huge problem if there was real
competition andrel is carving out an
alternative Pathway to secure DOD
contracts by buying up smaller startups
and small to medium-sized businesses so
when andal looks at buying companies we
typically want to buy companies that are
quite far along building something that
is differentiated that is far ahead of
what we have and that would be difficult
for us to catch up with and so what it
really comes down to is do they have
something that will become much more
valuable when paired with our core
product which is lce AI can autonomy
make this thing that they're making into
a much more powerful product and that's
been the basis of all of our
Acquisitions so far today defense
contractors produce small numbers of
large expensive heavily manned
hard-to-produce weapon systems the
so-called Moneyball military that
companies like Andel are working toward
will be made up of large numbers of
smaller lower cost autonomous systems I
don't think that andero will ever be
able to completely replace one of the
Prime contractors what they do is very
specific and very well honed uh we
unfortunately are in a very uncertain
world where great power competition is a
potential that's happening right now and
that great power conflict is a potential
that we all have to deal with and in
that kind of world the prime contractors
are going to be necessary to build those
huge defense systems the large primes
are struggling to do things the way
andrel does because they're publicly
traded companies with an existing
investor class that invested in them to
be a certain type of company at the same
time I hope they do get there I think
that maybe they're not going to get
quite to where andil is but I think that
we could get to a future where defense
companies are spending more on
developing their own products than the
government is I think that's a positive
world